okay.what welcome everybody to our
Thursday research conference and I
recognize most people here but it's
always good to see a few new faces
anyways today is the symposium that is
done by PhD students and our speaker
today is Ryan Swan who is a PhD student
in the bioinformatics and computational
biology tract although he's pursuing a
very clinical topic and his primary
advisor is dr. Mike Chang Ryan comes to
us from University of Wisconsin where he
received his bachelor's degree in
genetics and then spent some time
working with coop mcplantz and then he
decided that he wanted to work more with
humans and medicine so he enrolled in
our ph.d program for the last couple
years he's been working with dr. Chang
been funded through a training grant to
the k-ci Institute and will now be
moving this funding over to and Osler
tl1 which i think is from oaktree right
yeah okay so he's gonna go ahead and
talk let me just remind actually not
only those of you who are new but those
who are a longtime people to please
press the button and hold it down while
you're speaking if you ask the question
because that way it gets recorded on the
video and anyone out there in cyberspace
who happens to be streaming this talk
which all of our talks are can also hear
the questions as well and for those of
you out in cyber-land
if you want to ask a question yourself
you just tweet with hashtag D my scomp d
mi c e conf i will be checking it
periodically and we can answer those
questions I will turn it over to Ryan as
my
so um like bill said I've been working
with dr. Chang in k-ci Institute for the
past couple of years looking at
approaches to retinopathy of prematurity
and specifically talking a lot about the
genetics of the disease as part of the
bigger project that we're working on
we're kind of in the process of
assembling a lot of genetic information
and sequencing information about babies
that have this disease and we also have
a large cache of imaging data and we've
been working with a group at
Northeastern University that includes
jaishree Karpov Kyle Pepe Cramer who I
know some of you guys know and so this
is just kind of looking at the field of
retinal imaging as a whole and talking
specifically about the way that it's
been applied to retinopathy of
prematurity so this one specific disease
that's in that field so the way I'm
gonna split what I'm talking about today
I'm gonna spend a little bit of time
talking about what retinopathy of
prematurity is and talking about kind of
a history of retinal imaging and then
move into talking specifically I'm gonna
move through one particular set of
papers that forms a phtt to her PhD
student dissertation at Northeastern in
this project in this group that I've
been talking about because it works as a
really good example of the steps that
you have to go through in order to do
any kind of a project in this domain and
then I'll talk a little bit about areas
that we can improve on and areas of need
in the in the field and ways that we can
move forward with that so to kick things
off to start from a really basic level
the retina is the part of your eye that
lets you see it's the part where it's on
the back surface of your eye so the
light comes in through your lens and
then moves to the back of the eye and
it's perceived by this layer of cells
that contains these photo reactive
pigments that send signals to your brain
that basically say whether they've seen
a certain wavelength of light or not so
the neat thing about the retina is that
we can look just
look inside of the eye and we can look
at it which is unique as far as the
nervous system goes so it presents a lot
of really interesting opportunities from
an imaging standpoint because not only
can you see the nervous system you can
see a part of the circulatory system and
you can see it just with white light so
you can actually just take a camera and
this has been done for many years now
and just take a picture of the back of
the retina and see what a disease looks
like there are a lot of diseases that
fall into this spectrum too so I know at
the last last estimate that I heard was
at something like there on the order of
200 to 250 identified mutations that
lead to disease in the retina and in the
eye and it's also got an outcome that's
something that's very important to
address which is blindness because as
anybody can imagine that's a very
serious condition it's a very negative
final outcome for a lot of people that
can have big economic effects you know
people can lose their livelihood over
that and also just it's a huge emotional
burden for those people so this is an
area that we really want to address and
see if we can make it as good as we
possibly can so specifically retinal
imaging it's centered around this idea
of the fundus photograph so you have
this area at the back of your eye that
includes the structures that are
responsible for sight and specifically
the structures that are responsible for
your focus site and the thing about
ophthalmology standards is that
clinically a lot of them have a
phenotype that's been described in the
literature through photographs through
case studies things like that but they
don't have quantitative ways of
explaining those yet and so there is a
lot of room to talk about ways to bring
these things from a qualitative
perspective into a more quantitative
perspective especially now that we have
this huge abundance of imaging data the
other thing is that imaging is in pretty
much any ophthalmology clinic a lot of
pretty much any doctor has
so at least two fundus photography and
so the things that we identify in this
area can be translated to a lot of
different areas really quickly have an
immediate effect basic thing so when
we're talking about fundus photography
what we're usually talking about is this
particular apparatus here which is
throughout cam 3 which is a method of
acquiring photos you can see it's got a
little kind of gun thing that you
basically can take a picture of the
inside of the eye and it's a relatively
low resolution image kind of for what
we're used to these days at 6 640 by 480
and that's due to the way that these
things are okayed by the FDA so in order
to come out with an entirely new new
machine that does this you would have to
basically go through the licensing again
and so that's kind of one of the things
that holds us up at that lower
resolution that'll have impacts that
I'll talk about a little bit later and
this is something the first reck ham
system came out in the late eighties but
digital fundus photography has been
around since around mid eighties early
eighties though it's only moved into
clinical practice more commonly probably
over the past 15-20 years and there are
existing databases out there of images
but they're actually all quite small
like a lot of these imaging databases
only have some place on the order of 100
to 200 photos
one of the things that's necessary for
those databases is you a lot of times
have to have a manually segmented image
so you actually have to have somebody go
through and trace the structures of
interest on it like a human being and
that takes time and it's difficult to
get large databases of those and so
that's one thing that holds us back and
one of the other things that we'll talk
about a little bit toward the end is
that you can actually take many images
of the inside of the eye and stitch them
all together get a broader picture so
what are we usually interested in when
we're looking at these pictures from a
really broad level we're interested in
looking at the optic disc which is the
nerve head that reaches the
the retina so kind of where it's
connected into your nervous system that
direct line to the brain and then the
macula which is the main area that you
have your focus site on so where you're
where all of the light gets focused that
you can see a clearer picture or
something and then blood vessels which
you can see pretty clearly in this
picture and that's actually what I'm
going to be talking about the most today
just methods of looking at that
particular feature and try and break it
down and get some sort of quantitative
measure out of it and there's a lot of
other stuff that gets picked up on these
that can be a complicating factor
sometimes it can be something that makes
it more difficult or it can be a feature
of the disease you can have things like
hemorrhages you can have differences in
the way that the background of the image
looks so the way that the actual surface
of the retina is colored all these
diseases have different phenotypes that
manifest in different ways so give you
an example of what some of these things
look like through finest photography on
the upper left here you've got a normal
picture of a retinas that's the healthy
retina and then diabetic retinopathy in
the middle here is actually the
condition that most retinal imaging
studies have been done in because it's
an acute onset and it's a very it's very
necessary to diagnose it quickly and
move to treatment quickly and it affects
a very large portion of the population
and then there are some other diseases
here that show different phenotypes that
you can see like the liver congenital
amaurosis you have this splotch that's
over the macula ROP which we'll talk
about today has this characteristic
boundary around the outside and also
some blood vessel structures that I'll
talk about later macular degeneration
has these characteristic plaques and
retinal detachment has its own phenotype
so for all of these things you can see
that they're all pretty different and
that each one of these would need you to
create specific model that recognizes
that particular disease so that's a big
part of this and specifically today just
to give you an idea of like we're
narrowing in a little bit we'll be
talking mostly about retinopathy of
prematurity which is one of many many
diseases that exists this is one
approach inside of the larger approach
of
or one disease inside the larger kind of
domain of retinal imaging so retinopathy
of prematurity is specifically a disease
that happens in premature infants and
what generally happens is that you have
it's a regular development of the blood
vessels as they move out from where the
optic nerve is so as they branch out you
get this arrest and formation of a Ridge
and then a resurgence of the blood
vessel growth that leads to possible
detachment and blindness along with that
so that's a really negative consequence
like we've talked about and this was at
one point the leading cause of childhood
blindness and now it's come down
somewhat as a percentage but there are
more and more cases of this disease
every year because as we get better at
treating premature birth we have more
premature infants and even as the
quality of care improves that means that
we're seeing more and more cases of this
disease and since it is a relatively
rare disease we don't have a ton of
specialists that are able to diagnose it
and there have been studies done that
I've I'll bring up a little bit later
talking about how there is a significant
difference in diagnosis between expert
diagnosticians
and people who may not be an expert in
this particular disease and that limited
number of specialists makes it difficult
to get patients the care that they need
quickly it makes it difficult to make
sure that they get a consistent quality
of care so having an imaging standard
that we can look at would really help us
with some of these things and address
some of these unmet needs so the
specific features that make up our piece
we're drilling down another level we're
not just looking inside of the disease
we're looking or inside of like all
diseases really in one disease and then
we're looking at how that disease is
made up there are multiple things that
clinicians look at when they're trying
to diagnose this disease and one of them
is this idea of stage which is basically
just how pronounced this Ridge that
forms on the outside of the vascular
growth is the idea of zone which is is
it really close to the optic disc is it
farther away and this idea of plus
disease which is actually what we're
going to be focused on on the most give
you an idea of how
annular these things get and plus
disease is one of the characteristics of
ROP that is the most predictive of
whether a case we'll move on to this
more severe form that requires treatment
so if we're able to improve the
diagnosis of plus disease then that
could potentially have a really large
impact on diagnosis of this disease and
on basically getting people to care they
need at the right time making sure you
don't treat people who don't need
treatment which is also something that
we're worried about so drilling into
that and talking specifically about +
disease what does it actually mean to
have a + disease so right now what the
the clinical standard is is really just
these two pictures is that in the
mid-80s there is a study into treatment
of ROP that developed standards around
these particular features and basically
came up this idea of threshold disease
which is the level of disease that you
need to have in order to move forward
into treatment and that kind of has
stood for the past 25 years or so now
that I in the mid 90s there was another
push that developed an intermediate
level of this disease called pre plus
disease and it's difficult to say from a
quantitative perspective what you're
looking at because clinicians are really
just getting trained seeing a couple of
photos they're getting trained from
their own experience in their own
caseload and the cases that they've seen
themselves so really this is something
that we would like to have quantitative
standards we know that this idea of
tortuosity is like the twist enos of the
blood vessels and how much they branch
where they branch and how dilated they
are have some sort of effect and you can
see all those in this picture the top is
a normal eye and the bottom is an iowa
plus disease and you can see all those
things like the blood vessels are more
expanded you have a lot more twist enos
and playing like where the the path of
the vessels goes but it's difficult to
say when does normal become plus disease
and so that's really what most of the
imaging studies in this field of really
been looking at and
so to give an idea of how well experts
do when they look at this problem
studies have been done looking at inter
expert agreement looking at how these
these Raiders match up to one another
whether they're an expert or a non
expert whether you're looking at this as
just binary disease not disease or
you're looking at it with this idea of
the pre plus intermediate disease and
these are a little bit small but you can
see that while clinicians do pretty well
with the two-level categorization or the
three level categorization know while
you see at two level categorization
there are a lot of clinicians that are
getting fairly good results at the far
right of this that drops down
significantly when you go up to the
three level categorization this is
something that we've seen in the data
that we've been looking at too is that
there just seems to be a lot of play at
this level of pre plus disease where
people are kind of like is this Plus
diseases it's not plus disease and so
there's a demonstrated need there for us
to be able to find some sort of a
quantitative measure that puts that into
a more more objective standpoint
so in general when you're looking at
image processing there's a workflow that
you kind of go through depending on what
you're trying to do depending on whether
you're trying to visualize something and
show somebody a particular part of it
depending on whether you're trying to
turn one image into a different kind of
image that can be used for some other
purpose here we're talking about this
pre-processing tree where really what
we're trying to do is do this
segmentation which is the act of
recognizing something in the future so
the recognition is saying where is it
we're looking for some sort of a feature
where is it where are the things that
share this particular trait and then to
do a delineation to more directly
describe that in in a way that the
computer can understand it so with the
segmentation approach I'm going to start
switching over and start talking about
how this particular group dealt with a
lot of these challenges because it gives
a nice step through of each one of these
steps and gives you an idea of
I think that this is a pretty
generalizable framework like most of the
studies that I've read in this area go
through kind of the same thought process
they go through kind of the same steps
to get from the disease phenotype to the
final outcome classification that
they're looking for
so the segmentation problem in general
they're trying to look at blood vessels
so specifically a lot of these features
for this particular study in John being
able to pull out blood vessels from the
picture and then be able to turn them
into a tree structure basically some
sort of a binary binary tree and the
first thing that they need to do is
really just to pre-process these images
which you can see on the top right that
you need to get some sort of this this
idea of a mask that takes out a lot of
the detail of the image that you're
really just focusing on the parts that
you're the most interested in and so
what they do here is they run it through
a filter that essentially blocks out all
the background and assigns a probability
to each pixel of its chance of being
part of the blood vessel and then using
that they can take that processing and
threshold it to the point that they they
want it to be at and be able to apply
some sort of a smoothing algorithm to it
so here they're using this idea of
kernel covariance and you can see in the
middle one here that's the first path so
without any of the smoothing you end up
with this image and it's not really
coming through on the presentation but
there's a lot of salt and pepper noise
and that's kind of like in the
background there's a lot of spurious
noise and applying the smoothing to it
pulls that all out and gives you
something that might not look to a human
eye as much like you know it looks to
some degree like you're losing detail
but for the computer it makes it much
more easy to interpret it because you're
taking off a lot of that spurious noise
that could confuse it or kind of throw
it off so what do you get out of these
this is some examples of what normal
disease looks like and then pre plus and
plus disease starting from a picture and
in the center you
have the manual segmentation that's done
by a human being so you have somebody
that actually had to sit down with this
for 30 minutes 40 minutes and actually
trace through everything in Photoshop or
in a tracing program and then you have
how the computer reconstruct so and you
can see here that the computer misses
certain things it may not get as many
continuous surfaces it may not make
sense from an artistic standpoint the
way that a human brain can put this
stuff together but it does pretty well
and you can definitely see that there's
a difference between the normal and the
plus disease here so you can see that
it's pulling out features that are
likely to be informative about what
we're looking at so moving on from that
once you have that area basically what
what you have at that point is just a
big graph of pixels that have some
degree of probability associated with
them of being a blood vessel so that
doesn't give them one continuous
continuous unifying factor that tells
you about them so what you have to do is
move on to that delineation step that
was at the the figure I showed the tree
of the work flow which is to really
start to describe these things in bigger
terms that can be dissected and that you
can actually pull the features of
interest out of and so that gets into
this idea of tracing which is trying to
go through and find the center line of
the blood vessel so you're actually
trying to draw a line through all the
blood vessels that shows you right where
the middle of the blood vessel is and I
thought that this was an interesting
method that they used with this idea of
principle curves so really you're trying
to use you're trying to use the
eigenvectors and the linear algebra of
the space basically to tell you when you
stick all of these probabilities of
being a blood vessel together you can
basically stick a Gaussian distribution
so a little circular distribution on
there and then fit all those
distributions together and look at the
surface and if you just move up the
ridge that create
then you can trace together this idea of
principle curve that represents the
blood vessel and you can see how this
looks here you have at the top just sort
of like a bird's-eye view of this where
you have a heat map where the
probability densities are represented by
these colors so as you move farther and
you can see each one of these kind of
modular Gaussian distributions and then
on the bottom you can see what it would
look like if you projected this into
three dimensions and that starts to look
like something that makes sense I think
even as a human when you're looking at
if you just think of the idea like you
move up to a certain point and then cut
off the area below it you end up getting
this curve out of it
so once you've finished that you're
still not done you still have this idea
of needing to turn this into a tree so
you've got some sort of a curve you've
got some sort of an idea of where the
middle of the blood vessels are but what
you really want to be able to do is also
look at this and be able to say this is
a network of points this is a graph and
so what they did in their method is they
applied this principle spanning forest
method where they're basically looking
at the graph and trying to find the
cheapest way to traverse it so they look
at the distance on this two-dimensional
plane and they basically say like the
distance between two things is how much
it costs to move from here to here
what's the cheapest way to visit all of
the points that were interested in and
the problem with that is that is
actually an np-hard algorithm which
means that computationally it's
impossible to break it down to
polynomial time so you have to find some
way of doing that in a heuristic way
that cheats it you have to find some way
that looks at these points in a way that
doesn't have to do the best solution but
you have a pretty good chance of getting
a very good solution and what they do in
order to do that is they leverage the
Euclidean distance from the optic disk
so they can actually say like we know we
have this structure called the optic
disk we know all the blood vessels are
attached to this this
so we can set this point as our route
and then figure out distances from there
and that cuts down the amount of
processing time they have to put into it
so this does pretty well when compared
to the manual segmentation which is the
gold standard for this particular
process so if you look at this you can
see that they get really good
specificity and accuracy but their
sensitivity is a little bit lower but
for all intents and purposes it looks
like it does pretty well what it
actually ends up looking like is you
start with this colony and here's an
example this tracing was actually done
on top of a manual mask so this was done
on something that had been traced out by
a person just to give an idea of how
well it breaks it down into a tree and
you can see represented by different
colors at each one of these branch
points on the graphs so it seems like it
does a pretty good job and that is a
very useful feature to have for later
when we start talking about that idea of
the blood vessels branching and how that
will affect the diagnosis of plus
disease so kind of to go over the broad
strokes of what we just did you start
with some sort of an image you have to
do some amount of clean-up on it in
order to get it ready to go through the
whole process and once you have that you
go through and you figure out the
probability that each point on the image
is interesting to you based on what
you're looking at and then from there we
went and we turned that into this idea
of a tree so really we haven't found
anything yet to be honest like you you
haven't quantified anything yet so
that's when we start getting into
talking about features all we've really
done here is set a basis that allows us
to pull features out of this we now have
a structure that computer understands
that we can actually start applying
interesting measures to so when we're
talking about futures again coming back
to plus disease coming back to the
problem that we're worried about we're
thought thinking about this idea of
dilation so how wide the blood vessels
are we're thinking about the idea of
tortuosity so how is see the veins are
thinking about where the branching
happens because it's been shown that
branching that happens far away from the
optic disk is more likely to be
associated with plus disease so the idea
of the dilation measure is actually
pretty easy you just have this central
line that you found and you have the
pixels that you're interested in and
what you can do then is just go through
and find at points throughout each blood
vessel you draw an orthogonal line
through that center line and you end up
with this line that crosses into the
outside area of the mask and so what you
can do is you can just take the distance
that each one of those points and then
you can average it you can turn it into
a me and you can turn it into a
histogram but you can get that
information through that book what you
can see here is that as a consequence of
the fact that these images are
relatively low resolution you're really
not getting the best estimate of where
this blood vessel is at each one of
these points and this is an ongoing
problem the vessel dilation is actually
one of the traits that's the most
difficult to measure ironically even
though it has this very simple
algorithmic approach just the underlying
data is not in a format that makes it
easy for us to to measure it we can get
close so moving on from there you have
to come up with this idea of tortuosity
which gets a bit more complicated
because having a twist enos measure is
is something that you need to actually
kind of think about a little bit and
there is this idea of cumulative
tortuosity index which basically takes
the ratio of how curvy each section of
the blood vessel is over how long the
blood vessel is so what you end up
calculating is this ratio between blood
vessel how much it changes its
orientation as you traverse the blood
vessel and the curvature the so that's
the curvature over the length of that
the blood vessel from end point end
point and then once you have that you
can start thinking about taking
derivatives of that so you can look at
this idea of velocity which is how fast
that curvature changes as it moves
through
you can take the idea of acceleration
which is how fast that changes the
velocity changes as you're traversing
each one of these end points and you can
kind of see at the bottom here they have
this idea of what they have to do in
order to do this is you need to figure
out what one curve is so this idea of a
unit of a curve they go through and they
fit these cubic splines to the existing
structure so you end up with basically a
bunch of little line segments and each
one is one individual curve so you can
kind of see that in this image where
each one of those green lines represents
an acceleration vector that they're
getting off of one curve and you can see
on the right there where you have a
really strong curve where it goes down
and out really quickly that acceleration
vector gets much larger so this does a
pretty good job of capturing this idea
of tortuosity and a few different ways
like this is another thing that comes
through in a lot of these imaging
studies is that a multi-leveled approach
that captures multiple things about the
feature of interest is usually better so
this is a really neat way of getting
that out of it that was a novel approach
for this paper so the next thing that
you have to do is you have to start
looking at this idea of branching so
where does the branching happen how far
away from the optic disk does it happen
and the way that they quantify that is
they have this idea of looking at each
line segment so once you have the graph
you can quantify the line segment that
goes for the first level out second
level out and then you can just
basically count how many of those there
are as you move out through the graph
and the same way as you can look at
different derivatives of the velocity
the acceleration the curvature you can
do the same thing here and you can look
at how fast that changes as you move out
you can look at the ratio of how far
away from the optic disk it is to the
the set of segments that's farther out
so there's a lot of different ways that
you can look at that as well which is
again useful because you get a lot of
features out of them so to give you an
idea of what happens when you apply
these two images and you basically say I
want to see what an image that's really
high in category X or Y does
compared to a normal image you can see
here where they pulled out images that
fell at the extremes of these indices so
for the tortuosity index on the left you
can see what a an image with low
tortuosity and the blood vessels would
look like and on the right you can see
what an image with high tortuosity on
the blood vessels would look like and
you can see that pretty easily with the
naked eye but there's a lot more twist
enos and it has that more characteristic
look that's associated with plus disease
and then the branching factor okay on
the left you can see that there's
relatively little branching is even
farther away from the optic disk we're
on the right there's a lot of branching
as you move out you can see that those
blood vessels split into a bunch of
smaller blood vessels as you move away
from the optic disk and you can also see
that that's an ROP image because you can
see that beginning of the boundary that
gets formed on the far left side so it's
it's looking at the right things so you
end up getting out of this a huge bag of
statistics basically you get a huge bag
of of characterizations of these little
quantitative points but what does this
really tell us we still haven't gotten
to the point that we can say oh this is
a plus case oh this is not a plus case
this is someplace in the middle like you
still have to take this and turn it into
a model that predicts based on what it's
seeing what it's going to be able to
call that so you get a ton of features
out of this this isn't even all of them
here you can see at the bottom where it
says I mean main branch leaf node
factors and another figures so this is
only really having to do with the
curvature so it's it's still interesting
if you look at how many things you're
able to get out of just a couple of
simple measures what they do with that
is they basically take a bunch of
machine-learning measures and they have
data that's been trained or data has
been classified by experts so experts
have gone through and they've given
their idea of whether something is plus
disease whether it's not plus disease
whether it's pre plus and then they look
at different methods of combining all
these metrics into a classifier that can
find that and here they found
these SVM's actually did the best job
and that's actually really impressive
because 91% not only it outperforms non
expert readers and when you take into
account the fact that even experts have
a fairly large degree of disagreement
between each other the fact that you're
able to get 91% of the way there when
the experts that you're training on may
not necessarily all agree with each
other's diagnosis is pretty impressive
so now we've got a classifier and we've
got a bunch of features but you know
we're not done yet so it's like the TV
pitch for infomercials they're still got
more to do so we can actually take these
features and start talking about how
we're combining them we can talk about
what this tells us about the way that
clinicians look at disease so here on
the lower right they decided that they
didn't want to use the idea of just
looking at the mean or the mode which
are the ways that these features are
usually looked at they decided to look
at this as a Gaussian mixture model so
they actually have this idea that
there's a mixture of different
populations going on each one of these
measures and then they can combine those
together and that gave them a lot of the
predictive power that they had but they
also went back into this really
interesting study where they applied the
features that they had selected to
clinicians so they had clinicians go
through I'll show you
and look at a heat map or not look at
heat map look at actual cases of our
feet and they went through and they
looked at them and then each one of the
clinicians is on the left side here and
each one of the features is on the
bottom axis and so you can see that
certain features pop out more clinicians
are definitely looking at whatever this
feature 12 is they're definitely looking
at whatever this feature 43 is but you
can also see within this that there's
disagreement not all the clinicians are
looking at the same features so there's
kind of this diaspora what pieces of
information the clinicians are looking
at and this is just considering these
sort of two axes of tortuosity and
dialing
that we've been looking at so far and
branching factor so the first one here
actually ends up being the mean of the
Venus tortuosity so they're looking
specifically within the veins at what
the tortuosity is there and on the right
they have the branching factors that's
actually really really heartening news
because it means that not only did we
pick out good features we picked out
features that are exactly the ones that
clinicians are looking at already even
if they're not all looking at them the
same amount so where do we go from here
what other things can we do with this
data so one thing that's a very
interesting way to go with this is once
you have features you can start applying
it to a lot of different data types once
you can move through and you can pull
out this information you can get a lot
of different useful information that you
can apply back to something else and so
one interesting way of applying this
data is to look at the idea of genetics
and to think about how you could apply
this to that field and this is
particularly interesting to us because
we have a lot of genetic information
coming in we have a lot of imaging
information and this has been done
primarily in neurological diseases
they'll take these scans of the brain
turn them into an imaging feature so
they'll go through and they'll find
features that they're interested in
these things like cortical thickness
surface area and then they basically use
those as a quantitative trait loci so
they look at that the same way that you
would be able to go through populations
of people and check everybody's height
and then look at each one of their
genomes and see like how that shakes out
across that range of values instead of
just looking for a binary like either
you have the disease you don't have the
disease now you can start looking at
things that are specific traits and
saying is the level of this trait
involved in the genetic makeup that the
person has and those have been fairly
successful studies - is interesting so
they they don't even use very big sample
sizes a lot of these Alzheimer's and
cognitive impairment studies used some
place
between 800,000 people which is not not
a huge sample size for a genetic study
like that
the other thing that needs a lot of
attention and is this idea of gold
standard diagnosis because we've already
talked about how clinicians have
primarily been trained just using these
reference photos just using things that
may not fill in the blanks for them but
once you have a better quantifiable
standard of disease and once you can
approach this and kind of look at it as
a continuum of disease then you can
start developing educational tools you
can start developing ways of teaching
people based on different severa tees of
the disease and start talking about
where the cut points need to be within
there and that's all really useful
information and we've done a little bit
of work already in the past year talking
about educational tools that are based
on the imaging data that we've had
coming in but bringing in this
quantitative stuff would also move that
to another level so other things some of
these are improvements that are a little
bit beyond my power to make but clearly
we want to start seeing higher
resolution images of these models and be
able to get better estimates of things
like dilation of the veins and arteries
we want to be able to look at a lot of
these features that get washed out one
of the other things that's really
interesting about this is even expert
clinicians have a very hard time tracing
out some of these blood vessels so there
are very faint blood vessels that don't
show up on these images there are things
that we have a higher resolution image
we could be getting a better
quantification of that additional
information that we might not be getting
right now so that's another thing to
look at and another thing is to bring in
other imaging tools so optical coherence
tomography is a method of looking at the
three-dimensional structure of the
retina through a backscatter of light so
you have another non-invasive way of
looking at the retina and getting more
information out of it than we're getting
with just this fungus photograph which
gives you a flat picture right now and
folding that image into this and finding
more features in that data
type might also be useful and another
thing that's happening is that the eyes
not flat like you don't have square eyes
so a lot of work is starting to happen
with projecting these models into three
dimensions that you get a more spherical
look if I so that clinicians can both
look at it so you get a better
representation of the eye when you're
making these models and then of course
like this is only just one corner of ROP
that we've talked about so far so even
though this is the most informative part
of the disease it also has these ideas
of stage and zone threshold disease and
there's another axis of advanced
posterior ROP which is another form of
the disease which progresses in a
different way
and all these things need to be
quantified better so there's a lot of
space here I think to look at different
approaches and to improve the approaches
that exists so kind of to wrap
everything up I think that this is a
really good way of just looking at the
approach not just in ophthalmology but
pretty much anytime that you come to an
imaging problem what you're going to
have to do because it's almost always
going to have these ideas of
segmentation you're gonna have to
recognize the future you're looking for
you're going to have to put it in terms
that the computer can understand
Cicilline asian stuff and then you're
going to have to actually quantify it
and figure out what those features are
that you're looking at and more than
just one approach I feel like this is
kind of getting into what we talked
about when we talked about model
building like this is really kind of
like a model building Dogma that you can
follow and in general I mean like this
is a huge field this doesn't even cover
all the methods that were done by this
group so each one of the methods that I
covered actually had a secondary method
that backed it up but I knew I wouldn't
be able to get through all of them so
like there were two methods that they
were using that there are sandwiching
together to look at a tortuosity there
were two month methods that they're
sandwich doing together to look at the
branching the tracing they had two
methods that they were comparing it so a
lot of these things are multi-layered
within the approach and then also this
pulls from a huge huge amount of imaging
that happens
just a retinal imaging but in imaging is
whole and medical imaging so this is an
enormous enormous field with a lot of
space in it right now and that'll wrap
it up for me so thank you for coming
question very interesting it's certainly
a lot of work for single dissertation
but I can't help but think about you
know kind of the clinical correlates the
the data beyond your focus is mostly on
what's in the eye which I know is really
important but it seems that there's a
huge amount of opportunity to look at
clinical findings vision prognosis
things like that are there any people
doing that do you plan to take a look at
that now or in the future um well
there's already been some I think for
feature recognition I don't know of as
much in this particular I know there's a
lot of work going on and diabetic
retinopathy but this is something that's
building up over time to like you really
need to have large databases of curated
images which is another thing that I
think that we're really lucky to have
here is that as part of this project
Mike and two other people have been
looking at groups of images and coming
to consensus diagnosis on all of them
which is something that is really useful
because you get a better concrete
example of what you're actually training
on and it's I think it would be
difficult but probably possible to start
looking at things you know an EHR and
other other avenues but like really this
this feature recognition thing is kind
of the same as just applying machine
learning methods so I think that a lot
of that is already going on with you
know things like emerge trying to look
at more ancillary data in health record
and try and find things that are
informative so I think that that's a
really rich area that's definitely
evolving there's definitely a lot of
work going on in it
between them looking at a minimal
spanning tree when you're trying to
measure tortuosity how do those two play
together in two different ways so the
it's kind of I mean you can kind of
imagine like a tree for the data to like
the data gets split up in different ways
there's not one unified central
structure you end up with that that
center line tracing and then for the
tortuosity they have this idea of point
based and segments based measures where
they basically break it up into all
these little smaller chunks and they
measure those little chunks then they
look at them across a segment or look at
them across some span and with the tree
they have the tree structure and they're
looking more at just the the junction
points so they're actually just looking
breaking it into big segments and then
looking at each one of those big
segments and how far away they are as
you move farther and farther out so it's
it's kind of two versions of the same
data set but it's I mean you're right
it's really it's two separate things and
that's something that comes through in a
lot of this too is when you're looking
at these clinical diagnosis I mean again
that's only to diagnose one facet of ROP
which has these other things that are
also going to have to be diagnosed this
idea of stage and zone so it's I think
it's just kind of like all of these
methods end up being in sambala methods
to some extent where you're really
generating the features that are
interesting to you in as few steps as
possible and then going back and and
looking at them as an aggregate and so
that's where the classifier comes in to
is the classifiers this SVM that they
apply to it takes these populations of
information and then combines them in
order to make some sort of a call it
makes its classification call so I think
that that's I mean does that answer I
know what you're thinking yes thank you
okay thanks
you mentioned the FDA and to tell us a
little more about that and the striving
to improve the resolution problem um I
don't know a ton about it this kind of
that kind of came out of conversations
that I had with with Mike we're talking
about it but my understanding is that
the RET kam actually has two different
versions of the wreck cam three where
one of them is lower resolution and one
of them is higher resolution now but
they didn't update the name of their
product or it doesn't sound like they
advertised it quite as much so I mean it
really just seems like it's kind of a
licensing issue and just also the fact
that this is kind of in each market so
there isn't a lot of competition to
improve it so in order for them to go
through the whole FDA reapplication they
would need to have enough financial
reason to do it and I think that that
sounds like that's the reason is that
there's just not enough people chomping
at the bit for higher resolution yet for
it to push through the next thing even
though the technology is readily
available binary classification or the
idea here is to actually come up with a
severity scale because I mean this is
another thing that's come out of
conversations I've had with people it
doesn't sound like clinicians really
necessarily want to have a binary scale
that just tells them this is this this
is this because that opens them up to
the possibility of getting in trouble if
they disagree with the model and then it
call one way or another and so there's a
lot of work going on right now and the
same group is doing this at Northeastern
getting getting clinicians like Mike to
look at thousands of images and look
between the two of them and say of these
two images which do you think is the
worse like which one of these is more
necessary for treatment and then
combining the aggregate of all these
calls they're hoping that they can get a
big scale where they have a severity
index of thousands of images where it's
like this is the least this is the most
and then you have a continuum in the
middle
but the classification that they did in
this paper that I was presenting was
binary was my understanding is that they
were actually saying whether it matches
A+ whether it nice is the plus or at
this level that's what they're doing but
they're working towards a more
continuous scale wondering if you've
seen any deep learning I haven't seen
that but that's definitely something
that I thought about like there's this
diabetic retinopathy challenge that's
going on on cattle right now and I'd be
willing to bet that something you know
deep learning or there's it seems like
these convolutional neural nets have
been doing a really good job with image
identification so I wouldn't be
surprised if something like that ends up
winning the competition it's difficult I
think with clinical diagnosis to have
something that ends up being a black box
like you need to be using a classifier
that tells you kind of what it's looking
at and I think that the way that they
they do it here gives them a really
easily quantifiable way of saying this
is what we're specifically looking at
and I think that that's one of the big
considerations it's like they don't want
to just say like you have you have ROP
we don't know why I think you want to be
able to give a contextualized response
to that
thank you